we have the polling data right here from
Rasmus and 1 000 Americans the question
they asked was do you agree or disagree
with this statement quote it's okay to
be white now I think one of the things
that people need to understand here
especially Scott Adams is the people who
responded may have already seen the
media campaign that claimed the phrase
it's okay to be white was a racist dog
whistle right in which case that 26
percent may be like I saw that in the
news that the white supremacists were
putting that stuff out there so no I
don't agree with it right that's not
like if I saw Paul that said is it okay
to be black like I would I would like
I'm not going to answer these questions
right stupid do you agree with black
lives matter could be a similar question
and you're like I don't like the
corporation so I say no but if you do
believe that black lives matter in
general exactly if someone the question
would be Do You Believe In Black lives
or do you believe black lives matter and
that means two things
in the general sense the the the uh
proper we could say the proper noun is
do you believe organization quote
bracket black lives matter and then the
the the generic is do you believe that
black lives in fact matter to other
people like
because black lives matter is an
organization that question means two
different things to different people you
know do you believe in do you believe
you know do you support do you support
black lives matter are you talking about
the nonprofit or the general concept
whatever we're not going to tell you
because then what we're going to do is
once we get the answer we want and most
people say yes we then put out our
answer saying when surveyed most
respondents said they did support the
organization black lives matter and I
would get when I was doing a lot of
administrative Minds I'd have to look at
like is this too hot for TV kind of
stuff and stuff would come in and say
it's okay to be white and then it would
show like this white woman with like
long blonde hair in a field with like an
Aryan race symbol on the on the picture
and it's like everything about that's
legal but I know what they're trying to
say is it okay to be a white supremacist
it's okay to be white and it's okay to
just tell everyone I'm white and it's
great like it's okay like at some point
you got to stop being racist it's not
okay to be racist like it doesn't matter
what your skin color is at some point
um what does that mean it's not okay to
be racist I clarify that just being
racist I mean I I like talking about the
difference in genetics of races and
historological you know things like that
if that's considered racism then that's
I think that's an okay conversation but
if you're going to make your life future
choices based on what happened in the
past that's a mistake but don't or based
on what skin color people have that's I
think I think the issue is what kinds of
people do that I think the problem is
that we're we don't want to implement
government based on race we don't want
to implement policy based on race we
don't want to give out loans or anything
based on race we want to judge people
based on the kind of their characters if
an individual holds a belief I don't
know if that's not okay or okay morality
and ideas change so if some guys got
really bad views and keeps them to
itself like that's fine you can believe
whatever you want to believe just don't
go around hurting people that's true
it's okay to hate it's just not okay to
act in violence People based upon it but
Scott Adams is getting his like he's not
getting published anymore because he
expressed his personal opinion on his
own podcast like is that's just cancel
culture at that point right he's allowed
to have an opinion we don't agree with
does that mean that his work where that
work is not going to be canceled he
didn't have something to do with this
right he didn't publish a poll where
like or like a cartoon that has this
poll quoted in it right he did tell
people to can you imagine Dilbert coming
out and being like hey dogbert I
recommend you yeah he told me he
actually would be healed I believe he's
like his black white identifying
character Adam is like I've got to move
because it's crazy out here he told
people to segregate I think that's the
big problem of this video it wasn't just
him saying this is how I feel he was
saying if you're white you should get
away from black like that's to me is
insanity but it's his opinion though
like should we cancel him over his
opinion well his stuff was only on
people's newspapers because they their
opinion was that it was good right but
that didn't change the content of his
work right like if you had someone who
mows your lawn and he said to you like I
love communism it's awesome like maybe
you'd let him go but also maybe you'd be
like but you do a good job and you show
up on time for work so you can don't you
cannot not a group of things that I
believe you know every current theme on
the show is don't don't give them your
money to people that hate you exactly
agreed don't don't don't don't fund bad
things so at this point I'm kind of like
I don't know if a guy came out and was
like I'm here to mow your lawn but I'm
also a hardcore communist and the money
you give me I'd probably turn that down
I mean have a nice day bye it's hard for
me to criticize because for a year and a
half we told people who voted for Biden
that we literally didn't want their
money so it you know with cancel culture
is tough I mean you you have to uh I
think a better way for him to phrase it
would have been look if this poll is
right and if 26 of people have uh an
opinion of you that's obviously not
going to change and and is an untenable
opinion then maybe you should think
about how you organize your life to
avoid those kinds of people people who
think uh poorly of you now you you know
that's you can take that for for what
what you will I mean it doesn't mean
that you have to move away from black
people it means that you don't want to
be around people who think that you're a
bad person I mean I don't want to be
around people who think I'm a bad person
either I'm not going to hang out with
people who
um you know are critical of me being in
the gun industry right and you know tell
me that uh you know your business is
built on the backs of dead kids or
whatever I mean I you know I'm not gonna
have a beer with that guy yeah but you
know there are plenty of people in my
gym I train with who
um are uh Democrats and are on the
liberal end of the spectrum and and you
know but but we get along like we can we
can tease with each other and you know
we're we're friendly enough that we
don't have to separate ourselves but I
think if you're going to do something
like what uh Scott Adams did like you
better have all your ducks in a row
because you are going to get canceled
well he he knew this you better have the
interesting it already said in advance
and I think the issue is that he's
almost right in that if you're talking
about a group of people that outright
say they don't think it's okay to be a
certain race like you don't want to live
near those people if you're of that race
so if you take the racial context out
that Scott Adams had black people are
white people or anything like that and
say
if 26 of a racial group said it is not
okay for you to be that racial group
would you want to live by them imagine
if it was the other way around imagine
if the poll was white people ask is it
okay to be black and a black guy said
you got to get away from these people
well the reality is they say it all the
time these activists not all black
people leftists activists say all the
time get away from white people
whiteness is bad there was a one of the
a guy who was editor-in-chief or at
Fusion had his Twitter band said down
with whiteness with a bunch of black
fists and I'm like all of that stuff is
widely acceptable in the corporate press
it's widely acceptable to these
newspapers ABC News funded and a Disney
Corporation Univision Corporation was
absolutely 100 okay with their
editor-in-chief putting up a Twitter
Banner saying down with whiteness okay
so when Scott Adams comes out forgive me
if I roll my eyes a little bit and don't
care that much that a guy has an opinion
I don't agree with because I am swimming
in a psychotic racism of the left for a
decade or longer yeah I think you're
right it just reminds me of the
conversation that we've had about a
national divorce right whether or not we
actually formally enter a war culturally
people are pulling away from each other
because they feel as though they're
being pitted against one another which
is ultimately extremely destructive but
you can't blame someone of any race if
you're told this race hates you or this
race is constantly oppressing you why
would you want to live next to them
right if you're fed that constantly it's
meant to keep you apart I'm not
surprised that Scott Adam who seems
extremely depressed in this video is
like yeah I don't want I don't want to
be around someone of this race who
apparently doesn't like me but what kind
of short-sighted mind would look at a
poll of a thousand people I don't even
know if he knows that how many people
are in the poll would look at a poll and
then make a life decision about all
people based off that it's just a low
hanging like mentality that that kind of
mind it doesn't sound like it's based
off this one poll because he already has
moved away he said you know what I mean
like he is showing signs that this is
confirmation of something he has already
felt and now we're just seeing it in
hard numbers is like if you have a
feeling about something and then it gets
confirmed in the data even if the data
is not the best source it's hard not to
then be like okay I made the right
decision moving away because he's
talking about it in the past tense I
don't know that's just my perspective on
it I think that he seems like this is
confirming something that he is already
upset about it but it's like what kind
of data is he using to confirm his his
suspicions like it's it's a thousand
it's not good data but like I said he's
been slowly canceled for years and years
and years I mean they've been yeah the
right calls him clot Adams was he all
for the vaccine or something
so he gets canceled on both sides but I
mean I can respect him for at least
speaking up as he you know as he
believes he's clearly I wouldn't call
the guy a grifter no he's just going at
anybody he disagrees with him saying
exactly what he thinks even when
everyone's yelling at him he's like
that's what I think when he in the very
beginning of that video he was like the
thing is All Blacks the thing about
blacks he's not even like black people
blacks it's like a 1950s too yeah I
think he calls them white he might he
might say whites later in the video it
says it once blacks it's like a 1950s
George McGovern racism oh come on I
don't call people I feel like you you
think I'm upset about him so you're
you're reading more into it like if I
told you oh yeah this guy said this
crazy thing like you may not feel the
same sort of vitriol like it seems like
you have a specific antipathy and like I
don't it's very rare that well-known
people come out and tell me to segregate
away from black people it was freakish
to hear this come out of a guy's mouth
really but if a black person said to you
like I don't like being around white
people I'm Gonna Leave would you be
angry at them yeah I'd be also freaked
out that's crazy really yeah I don't
yeah they do it all all people of
actually
except for white liberals who hate being
around white white people every racial
demographic self-segregates I understand
like you want to be around what you're
familiar with to an extent
there's literally
Nate so there are historical
neighborhoods that were by policy
created to be racially segregated but
for the most part these days it is all
self-segregation I understand wanting to
be around what you're familiar with but
to run away from someone is to me is
absolutely just the it's the antithesis
of of humanity run away so to be like I
it's not that I want to go where the
people look like me it's if someone's
mentality is I want to get away from the
people that don't look like me then
they're crazy you can make your Society
the way you want it it doesn't matter
why is that like crazy I mean it's just
like they're afraid for no justifiable
reason but what he's saying is they're
saying they don't think it's okay to be
the race that I have no choice but that
yeah the problem is running into is that
what he's really getting at is he
doesn't want to be around people who
don't think uh he should exist
rationally or don't think that he should
exist yeah they're questioning whether
he should exist but you can't tell that
from somebody based on their outward
appearance you have to have a
conversation with them and understand
where they're coming from hey do you
think I should exist I mean like that's
not just something that you're going to
ask remember when you move in so you
know he's taking it to the extreme and
saying well because of because they're
black and that's something that I can
visually see that I'm going to decide to
self-segregate from those people when in
reality you know if you had a
conversation with everybody on the
street who was black you know probably
almost nobody would actually have that
opinion but he's unfortunately taking it
to the extreme remember that uh not
having the conversation the guy was
being interviewed and uh it was like it
was a guy and a woman and the woman says
well you don't understand because you're
white and he goes what he's like I'm
black and she's like you are and he's
like yes and then she was like I didn't
know and she genuinely thought his
opinion that was because David Webb yeah
he's a conservative uh talk show host
yeah and she didn't know who he was so
she accused him of being a white guy and
he was like what it's like what are you
talking about these people on the left
they live in a world where race is a is
political Viewpoint right so if you have
a conservative political Viewpoint that
means you're white but but I mean it
literally that's what they call
whiteness they've they've now started
saying like uh Polish people aren't
white and I'm like Lou gradkowski is
blonde hair and blue eyes well it
doesn't matter he is not white and I'm
like okay you're basically just saying
people I disagree with are white thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time